[Music]
jared is with us in detroit hi jared how
are you
hey guys thanks for taking the call it
is a snowy day up here so
absolutely um i i've been listening to
you guys for about the last year or so
on a regular basis
i'm a 31 year old bachelor who's also
the primary provider and caregiver for
my two parents
um
right before covent hit i had a student
loan debt of 48 000
or so
um and i'm getting ready to pay that off
here at the end of the month
um so 23 months get that all cleared up
so my main question is
what would be the next best step
uh given that
um you know i'm
living with mom and dad and helping take
care of them
um in this time that they need
um as well
tell me about that
yeah so just um some chronic health
issues with both of them um financial
issues with them and i've been the one
to uh step up and uh lend a hand to them
as the civilians are out of town
so are you living with them yeah you
said he was yeah okay so so you're
getting free rent
oh i i'm actually i'm providing the
funds for the
so they're getting free rent how old are
they
uh late sixties
okay what's the nature of their chronic
health problem
um dad has lung and back issues mom has
just the aches and pains and
not able to you know take care of dad
herself
um she's unemployed he has been a
private music teacher for many years so
income was never
steady so they have no money
uh they're both on um social security
yeah and how much do you collect on
social security on them
um between the two of them it's just
under 3 000 a month
and then i went out um and the family
from my church uh provided an open door
for me and that's how i've been able to
pay off this stat um they brought me in
they own the landscaping company and
they brought me in to run the office and
run the sales department
last february and it's been a great
opportunity
and i'm looking to stay with them for
years on down the road
okay are you 41 years old and still
doing this
31 no i'm saying 10 years from today
um at least doing the job with them yes
no that would be your parents but
if that's what is needed that's what i
would say yes
because i feel morally obligated to do
that
okay
um but i would also uh since i'm gonna
be paying off the debt
um i would like to step
if i have to yes sir
okay
i really appreciate your
sense of honor
and i appreciate your heart
um
that's not sustainable i disagree
and it's not a moral obligation for you
to give your life away to take care of
these folks who did not bother to take
care of themselves just because they
happen to be your dna and i'm not trying
to be cold or mean but uh when i when i
do this on a short term i'm with you but
when i stretch it out 20 years i'm no
longer with you on it
you and your siblings need to arrange
for their care a different way so that
you young men have a life
that's the hard thing is that the
siblings will not speak
yeah
why
because of the way my dad acted
i don't know yeah i know i've tried to
try and
you know
bridge a gap because i do respect that
they have their own families
and then like hey i'm the one here with
mom and dad how can i help and they go
they've not really given me anything to
try and
pursue any options yeah
do you have dreams of having a family
getting married all that
if the lord wills
i just don't want to see you held back
by all of those opportunities because
you're taking care of mom and dad i want
i'm not suggesting we throw them in the
street and that we're cold and that
you're dishonorable you are a very
honorable young man and i appreciate
that there's not many people that are
honorable anymore and i really
appreciate your sense of duty um it's a
wonderful thing but i do want you to
think beyond
uh on this and and start
what you've laid out here is not a
sustainable
quality of life for you
and it is not honorable at some point it
just becomes dysfunctional
so you've got to reach out there and say
okay
we're going to reach a point where we're
going to change this living arrangement
to x or y
and we're going to get the siblings
involved or mom and dad we're going to
find something they can live on uh you
know it may be medicaid nursing home at
some point because they would qualify
for that um it may be whatever i don't
know and i'm not trying to throw them
out in the street today
but this uh we're going to do this in
perpetuation and call it honor i'm not
with you on that i'm going to disagree
even though i admire your honor and i
admire your principle and i think it's
wonderful
for a period of years even that you take
care of them i have no issue with that
but this idea that you do this for 20
years is absurd dude it's absurd
so you need to rethink how we're going
to take care of them who's going to get
involved how we're going to
house them and feed them
so that you can begin to move past this
because this is a very very
um
it's not it's just it's not emotionally
spiritually financially sustainable yeah
and i'm hoping maybe we can get mom back
to a certain level of health where she
can take care of dad if she's in better
shape
you know get her health taken care of
versus you having to put your life on
hold to do this yeah you just got to
start finding some kind of an off ramp
somewhere out there in your mind rather
than in perpetuation and when you've got
that then that will affect the answer to
your question see
that will affect how you work out the
baby steps how you build wealth how you
have a life how you do these other
things because the girl that's going to
marry into this situation doesn't exist
she's not there
um
you know it's a hard pill to swallow but
well it's just she's not i mean it's not
and it's not because she's dishonorable
yeah
or mean or lacking in mercy or something
like that it's just she's going to
recognize this
as a mess and not jump in the middle of
it we're seeing this this trend the
sandwich generation what they call them
you know millennials gen x they're
having to take care of their parents
they're trying to take care of the kids
and it just puts stress on everyone it
can create resentment it can leave you
broke because you can't hit your own
financial goals you're trying to support
everyone on all ends yep that's a toxic
situation yeah and and you there's a
you know henry cloud's book boundaries
just what we're talking about here
and again it's not lacking in love it's
not lacking in principle it's not liking
an honor
uh it's not lacking in morality
uh you know
honor the bible says to honor your
father and mother it does not say to
honor their misbehavior it honors the
position of father position of mother if
your mother does cocaine we're not
honoring that that's not what the
bible's talking about if i was talking
about honoring the position of mom as a
position but not mom's misbehavior it's
about respect mom's dysfunction or dad's
misbehavior dad's misdis dysfunction
that's not what we're talking about and
so
you know uh but somewhere out of these
two you ended up with a tremendous sense
of duty and that
that's a wonderful thing for you to have
it's going to carry you a long way in a
positive way if you learn to
put reasonable guard rails on it